charles darwin is famous for his theory
of natural selection
or survival of the fittest
as it's known colloquially
though not formally termed by darwin
more tolerant to stress better at
catching prey or better at hiding from
predators
these individuals survive
they have sex they pass on their
genetics
and the process repeats
but this is at the level of individuals
within a
species and while we are still somewhat
evolving for better or for worse
a time scale of evolution that we can
observe is that which goes on inside of
us
cellular selection or cellular
competition as we will discuss all about
in this video
because it's interesting to think about
if survival of the fittest occurs in
cells too
then us being composed of trillions of
cells you may think that over time as we
age ourselves would get fitter
as they've out-competed the less fat
cells
so then why do we age
well i thought i was alone in my
thoughts about this
but then i actually did some research
and of course i'm not
so let me explain what we do understand
about this potential paradox in this
video
so firstly we need to consider what do i
and the fields mean by cellular fitness
and cellular competition
well my first understanding of cellular
fitness probably came from sperm
swimming to firefly's neck
if they can't move or migrate in the
right direction then they have no chance
of fires lies in the egg
to those that can have better odds they
are more likely to be winners
but while sperm competition is likely
considered an example of cellular
competition
i was more interested in understanding
cellular competition in somatic cells in
adult bodies
so the cells that make up are different
tissues and organs that are not going to
be used to make the necks cheeky
but like with natural selection for
cellular competition to occur there must
be variation
a heterogeneous population of cells
whereby cells with higher fitness
have a competitive advantage over
neighboring cells that have
comparatively lower fitness levels
fit cells are then selected to populated
tissue
while less fit cells undergo elimination
but is this really the case
well from a naive yet logical
perspective
cellular competition seems an
advantageous process for an individual
to have
and for which we now also have evidence
that it does occur
but it does raise many questions
what is a fit cell
what makes a cell fit
and what causes differences in the
fitness of a cell
how do cells know of their fit relative
to their neighbors
what are the mechanisms used
why do we age if cells are getting
fitter or does that mean they don't get
fitter
could we enhance cellular competition to
increase health span or lifespan
well lucky for you we will now address
each of these questions in turn
so firstly then what makes a cell fit
is fitness the same as health
now whilst i like to think i'm quite fit
if you think of a fit person you may
think of an athlete a celebrity someone
who is muscular in good shape
but actually fitness can be defined more
accurately as the ability to meet the
demands of the environment and relates
to how physically demanding life is
so a person doing an office job requires
lower levels of physical fitness than a
than an olympic athlete right
and so with many people working in
non-physical or sedentary jobs this
means that the fitness requirements of a
society decreases
the person is fit enough to meet the
sedentary needs of our lifestyle
but we could say they are not as healthy
and that's the important point
health which can be described as the
complete physical mental and social
well-being and not only the absence of
illness or infirmity thank you bbc bite
size
isn't the same as being fit we'll come
back to this later but for now what do
these definitions mean in the context of
cells
our definition of health doesn't really
work for a cell but fitness
is about the cell being able to meet the
demands of the environment and that will
depend on where what tissue and what you
the individual are up to and external
stresses you place on the cells
so now for the big question does
cellular competition even occur
well cellular competition and an initial
understanding of self-fitness
seems to first be described in many
favorites muzzle organism drosophila the
fruit flies in 1975
flies that had a genetic mutation in
ribosomal proteins these are the
proteins that were involved in making
more proteins
a cell needs proteins to grow and divide
the cells grew more slowly
when mutant cells were grown with
wild-type cells so without any mutations
in the winged disc of the drosophila
they were selected against and
eliminated
so the mutations made the cell less fit
so therefore we know that cell
competition exists but why and how do
cells compare their fitness
and why would that be selling a
competition
well currently there are three models of
cylinder competition
competition for nutrients and survival
factors
fitness sensing by cellular recognition
and then lastly mechanical cell
competition
in all cases the current definitions
reinforce that these are examples of
active elimination of the less-fit cell
it's not some passive process
and out of these three proposed
mechanisms
fitness sensing has been further
understood by one of the leaders in this
field eduardo moreno who is now starting
a group actually at the already infamous
altos labs where he showed in a landmark
2010 paper evidence for flower codes and
flies that enables them to sense the
fitness of their neighbors
yes you hide me right a flower code
now this actually has nothing to do with
flowers
but instead to do with a membrane
protein called flower
depending on which isoform of the flower
protein the cell was expressing it
predisposed the cell to be a winner or a
loser
so the flower code is like the cell
competition code that neighbouring cells
can use to work out if they're they're
fitter
but it also depends on neighboring cells
if they both have loser signals then
both losers remain
and this is an important point to
remember for later when we look at aging
but okay
but so why and how would this cause
cellular competition
well this leads us on to another
landmark study in 2015 showing that the
elimination of unfit cells maintains
tissue health and prolongs health pain
and drosophila again these fruit flies
they discovered in this paper another
protein that plays a role in the flower
codes and by manipulating the abundance
of this protein in the flies it impacted
their health and lifespan
this protein is called azorts implies
and as far as we know is a protein that
combines calcium and likely has a myriad
of functions within a cell
effectively what they show in this paper
is that cells that lack azorts are
unable to fitness sense suboptimal cells
so instead of elimination they
accumulate in the tissues
this helps the consequence of causing
tissue degeneration
whereby flies that lacked this protein
showed signs of accelerated aging
and therefore unsurprisingly they also
found that flies that lacked this
protein had a shortened lifespan with a
52 decrease in the median survival
compared to wild type flies
but even more interestingly flies that
had an extra copy of this protein lived
even longer than the wild type flies
showing an increase in median survival
of 54 percent
but anyway what this paper will suggest
is that cellular competition is
important for maintaining healthy
tissues and thus for aging and appears a
higher level sort of quality control
mechanism
but then this goes back to what i said
earlier
if we have this mechanism to select for
fitter cells
well why do we age
well from what i've read
there are two sort of theories that
could address this
firstly we start selecting for super fit
cells that may not be good for long-term
health
and then secondly
something starts to become defective in
a cell competition process
potentially a consequence of some other
aging hallmark
for example
in general cells become less fit due to
mutations over time
so
they might be selecting from an older
but
less fit population of cells
so the first point super fit cells then
that sounds well super
well think again super fit has been used
to describe cells that possess increased
expression of the protein mick
now mick is a protein a transcription
factor that you may have heard about if
you know about celina reprogramming
it's the m in oskm
and it worries people to have the m
because overactivity of mick is seen in
cancer cells
and so as again has benzene and
drosophila
if you have wild-type so normal cells in
a tissue
where there's also cells that have an
additional copy of mick
the mixed cells are super competitive
and take over the tissue
there's nothing even wrong with the
wild-type cells
and so this further reinforces the
comparative nature of cellular
competition
and so therefore selecting for super fit
cells could increase cancer formation as
we age
not good
but speaking of super this leads me on
to my next point about why we don't get
fetter cells of age
if everybody sleep off no one will be
comparisons and differences in fitness
levels are required for selling a
fitness to a car
so if all of the cells are less fit
then well total tissue fitness will
still go down
even if there is still some form of
selling of competition
now i don't really have much evidence to
back this up but it has two potential
consequences
firstly the organism is then less able
to detect pre-cancerous cells
which could lead to cancer formation and
death with the individual
and then secondly there could be a
time-dependent accumulation of unfit but
viable cells that could lead to
accelerated tissue and organ decay
now back in this 2015 drosophila paper
they did actually investigate both of
these hypotheses and found that the
cancer rate didn't change without this
asop protein
but flies don't really get cancer do
they
so you might be thinking all right
we can understand that cellular
competition is occurring in flies but
what about mammals
well elaine fuchs of the rockefeller
university in new york
has pioneered some research in cell
competition and mice
and her work interestingly shows that
depending on the stage of development
the cellular competition mechanism
varies
during early skin development
the winners kill the loser cells through
engulfment
whilst in late skin development the
losers are eliminated through terminal
differentiation
which means the cell has become the last
thing it will become and permanently
exits from the cell cycle
but the cell doesn't actually die
and so
loss of self-fitness sensing could be a
hallmark of aging
but for certain we need more evidence
from other higher muscle organisms
what is the equivalent of cell
competition in humans
is there an equivalent
did it just evolve senescence instead in
which case that's already a hallmark of
aging
or is cellulosin essence just a subset
under the bigger umbrella of cell
fitness
or is that completely separate to
senescence
ultimately we still seem to know very
little about how a cell may display its
fitness levels
but understanding this internal dialogue
may enable us to develop ways of
improving the odds of the cells that are
most beneficial to keep
sort of like how the sponsors in the
hunger games provide gifts to improve
the survivals of the candidates they
want to survive
we just don't know this language yet and
it is not the same language as the dna
sequence
it's some emergent feature
it seems to me that cellular competition
also overlaps a little bit with the
somatic mutation theory of aging
whereby the mutations that accumulate
with age might influence the fitness of
a cell
i made a video on this recently and how
the rays of mutations correlates with
lifespan across different mammals which
you can watch here
so with that i hope you've learned
something in this video thank you to my
patreon supporters and thank you for
listening